the reason that most times
with businesses that i take on in the
portfolio it's actually the first step
we do is we actually narrow it most
times and it's because they don't even
know who they serve and they don't know
who they serve best and so when you're
starting out one of the best practices
you can do is the fancy word is a common
factor analysis but basically what is
what are all the best clients we have
have in common so if we take 100 clients
and we look at the top 20 because
there's a pareto they're probably
responsible for 80 of the revenue
anyways we look at that 20 we say what
do they all have in common and then what
if we only sold that amount of people
and we sold now the same hundred but
they were all of that twenty percent
right well we would five x our revenue
same operational drag because it's the
same size company but we're selling
better customers i get on with
entrepreneurs all the time and they're
like i think i've saturated my market
and i'm like all right what's your
revenue they're like two million bucks a
year i'm like okay the market you're
serving is a 60 billion dollar industry
and you are making two million dollars a
year do you feel like it's like do you
feel like like you might be premature or
you just don't know how to get more
customers
they're like well i guess i don't know
how to get more customers like that's a
problem that's solvable so let's solve
that